oui
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de la grande interview avec comme invité
cette semaine une personnalité qui se
fait très discrète c'est claudie
haigneré
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté cette
invitation vous êtes installé chez vous
afin de respecter les conditions
sanitaires que le coronavirus nous
impose
vous avez été astronautes et je suis sûr
que beaucoup de gens s'en souviennent de
vol dans l'espace
comment vivez vous cette période de
confinement qui nous oblige finalement
être dispensés dans ce dans ce climat
général qui est quand même
il reste très anxiogène bonjour vraiment
ravi de pouvoir passer ce moment avec
vous c'est vrai que je re préféré être
plus proche de vous et c'est vrai que ce
qui peut-être limite beaucoup c'est
cette possibilité de se déplacer d'avoir
des contacts et de d'entrer davantage
dans dans les changes dans la vraie
relation humaine et c'est peut-être ce
qui me ce qui me manque aujourd'hui
c'est ce que j'ai eu la chance de vivre
dans une aventure humaine effectivement
extraordinaire d'avoir le privilège de
faire deux missions spatiales avec des
coéquipiers les collègues des équipes et
on était vraiment dans cet échange
présentiel même si une fois dans la
station spatiale on est à addis tombe
effectivement à 400 km en orbite autour
de la terre c'est vraiment un travail
d'équipé avec à la fois l'équipage
et puis toutes les équipes qui se
marrent côté donc ce manque
d'interaction c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas gênant c'est vrai alors c'est
ce parcours auquel vous faites allusion
cette expérience cette expertise zee que
que vous avez qui fait que nous avons de
votre part beaucoup de choses à
apprendre sur la situation que nous
vivons actuellement on a plein de
raisons d'avoir envie de vous écouter je
disais en vous accueillant que vous êtes
une des rares femmes spationautes ou
astronaute je ne sais pas ce qu'on dit
on des astronautes 1 vous avez effectué
je disais un premier vol dans l'espace
de seize jours c'était à bord de la
station mir c'était en 1904
20 16 corrigez moi si je me trompe mais
c'était au mois d'août et dans le cadre
d'une mission franco russe
après vous êtes allez vous entraînez
vous êtes resté à la cité des étoiles à
la base spatiale de de la russie puis en
janvier 2001 vous serez la première
femme à voler à bord de la station
internationale iss
alors vous savez que le parrain c'était
en octobre 2001 il entend janvier
c'était en octobre 2001 j'ai donc merci
de me merci de me corriger mais vous
savez que ce mois ci un puisque nous
sommes en avril aura lieu le le 60e
anniversaire du premier vol spatial pour
un être humain c'était le vol de youri
gagarine c'était il ya 60 ans alors je
vais pas vu je vais je vais pas vous
dévoiler des indiscrétions mais vous
étiez vraiment très petit à l'époque
vous devez vous en avez un souvenir de
ce vol là ou pas non aux noms souvent
cette question de goût mais venus ses
désirs et ses taux à zahlé candidater
pour devenir astronaute
alors c'est vrai que j'étais trop petit
pour garder le souvenir de youri
gagarine en 61 puisque sans rien à ce
que je suis né en 57 au besoin du scout
nick par ailleurs le grand moment de l'
aventure spatiale et j'ai été
impressionné mois par ses missions sur
la lune ce qui entre 69 et j'avais 12
ans et voilà je fais un peu partie de
cette génération à apollo met par
ailleurs en ayant eu la chance de
m'entraîner effectivement avec nos
collègues russes puisque mes deux
veulent je les ai fait avec la fusée
soyouz et la capsule soyouz à bord pour
rejoindre cette station soviétique puis
russe la station mir et ensuite la
construction de la station spatiale
internationale
j'ai vraiment plongé dans une atmosphère
où j'ai vécu auprès de mes rozon plus
gaga arrive puisqu'il n'était plus là
quand je suis arrivé en 92 à
l'entraînement mais je vivais je
souhaiterais de valentina terechkova la
première femme à avoir volé dans
l'espace
j'avais l'appartement à côté de alexis
léonov donc voilà j'ai vraiment vécu
auprès de ces héros et gagarine était
présent à chaque point de bâtiments de
salles de sport de deux places de la
cité des étoiles près de moscou j'ai
passé 10 années l'entrainement oui mais
alors tout ce que vous racontez là avec
beaucoup de damour beaucoup d'affection
c'est le rêve de beaucoup de jeunes
encore aujourd'hui parce que la
recherche la conquête spatiale les
voyages ça fait rêver
comment est-ce qu'on comment est-ce
qu'on devient astronautes aujourd'hui
comment comment je vous êtes devenu fou
à ce prono je crois que vous avez raison
il faut avoir ce désir parfois c'est
carrément un rêve
et pour moi c'était un peu un rêve
c'était cette idée d'avoir accès à la
lune que ça soit possible en 69
côté hommes y soit c'est quelque chose
qui m'a ouvert des portes
et après c'est une rencontre de
d'opportunités moi j'ai vu cet appel à
candidatures du cnas l agence française
alors que j'étais médecin rhumatologue
travaillant à l'hôpital cochin et c'est
clair que ce rêve d'enfant a ressurgi à
ce moment là et j'avais la possibilité
de saisir l'opportunité saisir la chance
j'ai eu l'audace de le faire est d'être
sélectionné jeudi parce qu'aujourd'hui
il ya une nouvelle sélection de l'
agence spatiale européenne qui va
démarrer très rapidement puisque les
dossiers sont à retirer au 31 mars
est ce que je dis aux jeunes filles et
aux jeunes garçons c'est alesi osé
tenter votre rsa sera un parcours long
difficile il y aura très peu d'élus en
fait dans cette sélection
mais si vous ne tentez pas si vous
n'osez pas commencer le chemin de votre
rêve n'y parviendrez pas et moi j'ai eu
la chance de vivre en rêve donc là c'est
intéressant
en fait vous faites un appel à
candidatures quoi vous d'italie lâchez
vous êtes faites ce que vous avez
vraiment envie de faire parce que kiki
qui mérite qui ne demandent pas darien
finalement absolument et je le dis pour
d'autres métiers aussi c'est vrai que
cette jeunesse elle doit essayer de de
tenter sa propre aventure et pas
obligatoirement de suivre des modèles
qui lui serait imposée jeudi
effectivement cette jeune génération aux
et prenez votre destin en main
formez-vous 1 il faut avoir
un bon bagage il faut avoir tous les les
compétences qui vont vous permettre
d'avancer sur le chemin mais tentez
votre vie oui
alors qu'est ce que ça vous a appris la
recherche spatiale
qu'est ce que ça vous a apporté en
dehors de cette passion de cette la
réalisation de cet enthousiasme de ceux
de la réalisation de ce rêve alors au
départ je suis donc médecins et puis le
coeur en neurosciences donc avec des
programmes de travail de recherche
scientifique et c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment ce qui m'intéressait de me
lancer dans cette ses programmes
spatiaux en orbite un laboratoire une
station spatiale en orbite c'est un
laboratoire dans lequel on se trouve en
situation de microgravité la force de
gravité n'exerce pratiquement plus
d'effet sur le corps humain sur des
structures biologie végétale sur des
fluides sur la combustion donc c'est
tout un panorama de recherche pour
lequel il n'y a pas de laboratoire au
sol donc en tant que chercheur et en
tant que médecin pour voir les capacités
d'adaptation d'organismes j'étais
passionné par découvrir cet
environnement puis au fur et à mesure
des entraînements j'ai appris à
maîtriser et système très complexe
une fusée une capsule un amarrage une
station spatiale ça maintenant son
organisation donc lâché passer d'une
compétence spécifique à de multiples
compétences puisque un astronaute en vol
c'est un opérationnel qui doit trouver
les solutions aux problèmes qui peuvent
se rendre et qui est avec son équipage
dans l'objectif de réussir
on est successeur lee hunter et ça c'est
quelque chose d'important quand on se
fixe comme objectif de réussir et de
trouver les solutions
en général on arrive à passer au travers
des soucis des désillusions et les aider
pessimisme parce qu'on met toute son
énergie pour pour avancer et j'ai donc
vécu une formidable aventure
scientifique technologique mais aussi
cette aventure humaine de rencontrer
d'autres gens d'autres cultures d'autres
profils professionnels et ça c'est
quelque chose qui m'a marqué à vie bien
évidemment et qui fait que j'ai toujours
cet enthousiasme à partager alors vous
avez vécu
tout ça à un moment où la recherche
spatiale était très active
j'allais dire très spectaculaire parce
que bon il ya eu les programmes auxquels
vous avez participé mais vous avez fait
allusion au programme apollo américain
tous les voyages sur la lune tout ça et
puis il ya eu une grande parenthèse
pendant laquelle on a eu l'impression
que on mettait tout ça de côté pour
s'occuper d'autre chose et puis on
revient aujourd'hui on revient
aujourd'hui on le sent avec le voyage
sur mars avec les programmes d'ordre
privés que sont en train de lancer l
unesco aux états unis qu'est-ce que vous
qu'est ce que vous attendez de ces deux
sets de cette résurgence la 2e de ce
retour en force avant d'arriver à ces
nouveaux programmes et vous avez raison
le paysage change beaucoup aujourd'hui
je voudrais déjà insisté sur les 20
années qui viennent de s'écouler les
vingt années d'occupation permanente de
la station spatiale internationale
station spatiale internationale avec
cinq partenaires outil diplomatique
fantastique qui a permis de continuer à
travailler avec ruth l'américain
japonais canadiens et europe / voilà des
missions complexes et je vous avais dit
que j'ai volé en 2001 tout début de
stations spatiales y avait un mobile
russie un module américain c'est tout il
n'y avait pas encore de module européen
pas encore de module japonais pas encore
de bras robotique canadien et tout ça
c'est un seul et et pendant ces vingt
années on a vraiment développé une
science et excellence dans la station
spatiale internationale donc on peut pas
dire qu'il s'est rien passé on a appris
à travailler ensemble et on ya installé
un laboratoire magnifique mais
maintenant effectivement ce que je dis
aux jeunes gens du 21e siècle
vous avez les opportunités absolument
extraordinaire on est en train de
prévoir le retour sur la lune
et cette fois ci pour rien rester sur
des séjours de longue durée dans des
habitats permanent avec d'abord une
infrastructure autour de la lune puis
des bases sur la lune de façon à
préparer ensuite l'étape objectif ultime
ou comment la dcri de pouvoir avoir une
mission habitée vers mars qui sera quand
même dans quelques dizaines d'années je
pense on est tous admiratifs de ce qui
se passe en ce moment avec le rover
persévérance sur la surface de mars
alors vous avez raison il s'est pas
passé de choses très spectaculaire
pendant une vingtaine d'années
mais vous avez énormément travaillé à
ces programmes là il ya eu aussi un
travail de l'industrie il ya eu un
passage industriel avec les lancements
de satellites de télécommunication et ça
a été le développement des
télécommunications
mais sur toute la la dernière partie
celle que vous venez de d'amorcer et
d'introduire on va en reparler dans un
instant on s'arrête une poignée de
secondes
[Musique]
retour sur le plateau de la grande
interview avec notre invité claudie
haigneré que je ne présente pas c'est
une astronaute qui avait fait deux vols
dans l'espace p caf pour sacrer sa vie à
la recherche spatiale après avoir été
mais elle est toujours médecins et elle
continue de de travailler dans le
secteur scientifique vous le disiez il
ya un instant on entre dans une nouvelle
phase de la conquête spatiale
mais l' aventure que vous avez traversé
que vous à laquelle vous avez participé
à une composante du moins pour
l'extérieur une composante politique
très fort ça a été un levier d'
influence de rivalité aussi entre
notamment les deux grandes puissances
mondiales qui étaient les etats-unis et
la russie
est ce que vous le sentiez lorsque vous
étiez opérationnel en russie pendant
toute la période où vous avez travaillé
là-bas alors je suis arrivé pour ma part
à l'entraînement à la cité des étoiles
en 1992 donc quand on évoque l'histoire
de l'union soviétique et de la russie
1992 c'est une date importante
absolument les transformations un élan
de coopération franco russe qui était
vraiment très important avec cette
impulsion de coopération scientifique de
longue date et qu'ils poursuivaient donc
j'ai j'ai démarré par cette atmosphère
de coopération scientifique franco russe
et c'est vrai dans les dix années qui
ont suivi on a vu s'ouvrir aussi ce
terrain avec la construction de la
station spatiale internationale donc
l'arrivée de de l'europe et des états
unis et du japon et du canada
donc c'était là aussi un autre versant
politique d'une population
internationales multilatérales pour
avancer dans ses objectifs scientifiques
et technologiques en commun on c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une
nouvelle période une période où on voit
émerger des puissances spatiales part de
la chine par exemple il ya un programme
ambitieux dans le domaine de
l'exploration où on voit effectivement
arrivée des acteurs privés qui n'était
pas du tout présent dans le panorama du
20e siècle et qui est aujourd'hui son
support aux agences institutionnels ne
peuvent avoir aussi leur feuille de
route
une personnelle et vous avez parlé ces
constellations de cet espace au service
du citoyen au quotidien que ce soit des
télécoms de l'observation de la terre de
la géolocalisation donc c'est très
foisonnant et c'est effectivement un
enjeu de démonstration capacité est un
enjeu de puissance
évidemment oui mais différent de celui
que vous aviez connu à au démarrage
puisqu'il y avait le premier homme dans
l'espace était russe mais le premier
homme sur la lune étaient américains
c'était une compétition vraiment entre
les deux entre les deux puissances
oui je suis pas sûr qu'on soit de
nouveau au temps des premières
on a vécu au 20e siècle le temps des
pionniers des premières épreuves et le
gagarine première sortie
extravéhiculaire premier homme sur la
lune avec cette compétition et cette
course entre effectivement en union
soviétique et les états unis
je pense qu'on est aujourd'hui à la fois
dans un esprit de coopération sur le
plan scientifique et technologique
mais bien sûr dans une compétition
exacerbée aussi parce que les enjeux
sociaux sont des enjeux majeurs de
puissance et d'influencé vous l'avez
rappelé est-ce que vous jugez que la
collaboration entre les français et les
russes à laquelle vous participez
puisque vous êtes membre indue du
dialogue de trianon est une initiative
qui avait été prise par emmanuel macron
et et vladimir poutine s'était en 2017 à
versailles je me crois est ce que vous
considérez que cette collaboration et
donne des résultats est satisfaisante
actuellement pas écoutez moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station millions ou
la station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie et de dix
jours on a très peu d'objets aujourd'hui
qui peuvent être des outils
diplomatiques aussi aux six ans et pour
moi le dialogue de trianon c'est aussi
cette plateforme où au-delà deux contre
un
de difficultés géopolitiques qu'on peut
avoir dans d'autres domaines
on essaie de maintenir ce lien de
coopération culturelle artistique
scientifique historique musical je parle
des franco russe par exemple qui se
tiennent en ce moment à à toulouse et
qui permettent d'avoir ses relations
sociétés civiles la société civile sur
des thématiques d'intérêt et par exemple
au sein du dialogue de trianon moi j'ai
eu la chance de participer encore tout
récemment à un concours d'écriture de
nouvelles destinées à la jeune
génération en demandant la jeune
génération russe
la jeune génération française comment il
se projetait dans un avenir où
l'intelligence humaine serait assisté
par d'autres formes d'intelligence
l'intelligence artificielle
il se trouve que de dépasser des
contraintes politiques pour essayer de
réfléchir ensemble dans une vision
d'avenir en faisant parler la jeune
génération en faisant parler la science
et la culture c'est important ça veut
dire enfin je comprends que si vous
voulez dire c'est que vous avez une
expérience politique vous êtes rentré au
gouvernement ce que les hommes
politiques se sont évidemment intéressé
à vous à votre expérience à votre
notoriété aussi et à votre parcours
est ce que ça veut dire que la politique
fonctionne vraiment mieux que
lorsqu'elle a des projets concrets et
aider des ambitions concrètes non pas
sur l'idéologie
mais sur le sur les faits et des hommes
moi je pense qu'il faut les deux il faut
avoir une vision stratégique est née
après il faut avoir des projets concrets
sur lequel parle à la connaissance
mutuelle et on revient au tout début de
notre interview
ce qui manque aujourd'hui quand on est à
distance en virtuel
c'est cet échange chaleureux ces
discussions vont parfois très vives
concret à voir mais qui font que et un
climat de confiance
et puis un objectif partagé qui
s'installe et ses points concrets c'est
la possibilité d'avancer en confiance
sur des objectifs à résoudre mais là
puisque vous êtes scientifique comment
jugez-vous aujourd'hui la relation qui
existe entre les experts scientifiques
et notamment les médecins et les
gouvernances politique on a vraiment le
sentiment que les gouvernance politique
dissimule derrière les experts se
dissimule derrière les scientifiques je
pense qu'il ya une expertise
scientifique et qu'elles doivent être
écoutés et quand je dis expertise
scientifique je parle d'une expertise
scientifique valide organisée et non
parce qu'on peut avoir parfois comme des
informations ou des informations sur des
réseaux sociaux où on est dans une
opinion et non pas tant de la
démonstration et des des formes
d'assurances scientifique mais que ça
n'est pas le seul élément à la
disposition du politique pour prendre
cette décision
mais ça veut dire que la collaboration
scientifique que ce soit dans votre
domaine ou même dans le domaine de la
santé puisque c'est l'actualité d'un
peut faire avancer les rapports
diplomatiques ça peut servir
les le rapprochement mondiale oui c'est
ce que j'évoquais sur la diplomatie
scientifique au niveau de la recherche
les laissons ouvertes je ne suis sûr que
nos scientifiques français reçoivent des
informations des scientifiques russes ou
des scientifiques américains en ce qui
concerne que ce soit les vaccins ou que
ce soit les thérapeutiques
éventuellement à appliquer et ça c'est
important de partager c'est cette
information salut propre de la recherche
scientifique
je rentre pas dans le champ de la
technologie de la propriété
intellectuelle quand on voit vers
l'innovation et la mise sur le marché
est un sujet différent
c'est à la base l'acquisition de
connaissances et les deux plus grandes
qualités se rapprochant d'une forme de
vérité s'il est partagé
vous avez été ministre des affaires
européennes comment juger le
fonctionnement et la gouvernance
européenne aujourd'hui il ya quand même
quelque chose qui ne va pas va plus
l'europe pour moi j'y suis très attaché
parce que j'ai eu la chance de voler au
cours de ma seconde mission pour
l'agencé spatiale européenne donc avec
un drapeau européen et les 22 états
membres de l'agencé spatiale européenne
donc je pense qu'il y a des tas de
sujets sur lesquels si on n'est pas sûr
non européens on pourra pas avancer
prendre des décisions s'approcher d'une
forme d'autonomie qui nous permet d'être
là
des décisions politiques parce que on a
un marché des règles de gouvernance une
pensée stratégique partagée
donc il ya vraiment des domaines où la
souveraineté du continent elle se fait à
l'échelle de l'europe gagne évidemment
sinon il n'y a pas de voie possible
par ailleurs je suis tout à fait
consciente de la difficulté d'obtenir
des consensus avec l'ensemble des états
membres qui peuvent avoir des éléments
de souveraineté plus plus fermé - - un
fusible
donc c'est pas la fois la richesse de
l'europe et sasl difficultés mais je
pense qu'il faut continuer à construire
cette fête europe qui peut nous
permettre d'avoir vraiment une voix qui
porte et une influence sur la table de
ses enjeux énormes
et puis à des endroits où l'europe est
quand même en leadership
je parle de la lutte contre le
changement climatique
les gens parlent aussi passé parce que
le secteur spatial apporte énormément
d'éléments pour comprendre l'atmosphère
le changement climatique
l'action des océans voilà on a vraiment
des choses à apporter à la table des
discussions
ne serait-ce que cette notion que en
multilatérale on peut avancer plus loin
quand on est ensemble
donc quand on est dans des oppositions
bilatérales parfois un petit peu un
petit peu stérile et et voilà la
recherche scientifique ça m'a appris
peut être aussi à tirer parti des des
connaissances de les ouvrir de l'est de
les partager alors c'est pas la même
chose en politique j'en suis conscient
et je les ai vécu aussi dans mon
exercice politique que ce soit la
recherche aux affaires européennes mais
je crois vraiment qu'il est important de
d'avancé et d'aller plus loin avec une
europe qui soit stratégique est sûre
d'elle-même et ambitieuse pour la jeune
génération
vous parliez delà de la protection de
l'environnement je profite
je profite de votre de votre commentaire
vous vous posez une question qui m'a
posé mon fils me dit demande si l'espace
est pollué avec tous les satellites
qu'on a envoyés dans l'espace depuis que
nous sommes les est ce qu'il n'ya pas de
ce qu'il y'a pas des pollutions dans
l'espace comment vous gérez ça est ce
que c'est une préoccupation
votre office a raison de poser la
question alors ce thème de
l'environnement d'ailleurs vous avez
évoqué le dialogue de trianon tout à
l'heure cette année 2021 en amis comme
thème de réflexion et de partage de
connaissances en commun ce sujet de la
protection de l'environnement
donc vous voyez que ça peut être aussi
un sujet sur lequel on se rejoint est en
avance ensemble
alors effectivement l'environnement
c'est pas que l'environnement de la
terre la banlieue de la terre l'espace
elle est écrit qu'il monte au pied de
satellites aujourd'hui et on doit être
très attentif et là on doit l'être en
multilatérale
bien sûr simplement un pays ou un autre
oui de savoir quels sont ses satellites
en orbite
quelles sont leurs trajectoires comme on
les surveille comment potentiellement il
peut y avoir des collisions dont des
débris spatiaux
c'est des sujets qui sont au coeur
aujourd'hui et des activités des
activités je dirais de coupe rôle
pacifique et réservations pacifique de
cet environnement qui nous sont pouvoir
je n'entrerai pas sur votre terrain non
mais la collaboration internationale
dont vous parlez elle peut fonctionner
sur ce segment de de préoccupation là
aussi évidemment il est indispensable
qu'elles fonctionnent sur ce terrain
parce que si on peut lui cet
environnement autour de la terre est
bien fraîche l'accès à qui que ce soit
d'aller plus loin sur l'exploration
spatiale et l'utilisation des bons pour
terminer est ce que je peux vous
demander si vous avez acquis la
conviction il y avait une vie possible
en dehors de la terre gelée pâquis parme
à ma connaissance roma rencontre
d'autres formes de vie par contre que
cette question se pose est que la
recherche justement et essaie d'apporter
des éléments de réponse c'est essentiel
c'est une question fondamentale
aujourd'hui on va sur mars
horrifiée voir si sur cette planète qui
étaient très semblables à la terre et à
8 milliards d'années y'a pas des formes
de traces d'une vie biologique
donc ça c'est une question importante et
ensuite notre système solaire il est
vraiment tout qui au sein de l'univers
et on lance aujourd'hui deux
merveilleuses mission pour mieux
connaître les exoplanètes des planètes
autour d'autres systèmes solaires et se
dire que dans ces milliards de galaxies
d'autres systèmes solaires c'est
multiples exoplanètes condé en train de
découvrir que tati at il quelque part
autre chose que notre intelligence
terrestre est humaine mais une de vos
passions personnelles si la lune
1 c'est ça votre obsession oui j'ai
beaucoup travaillé ces dernières années
sur effectivement l'installation sur la
lune infrastructures qui permettront
d'apprendre à vivre et travailler
et là encore c'est cette optique je
lisais de partage de le faire ensemble
une forme d'expansion de l'humanité et
si notre humanité doit progresser
grandir
essayez de penser ensemble et pas chacun
de son côté notre humanité elle est bien
sûr diverses mais elle est une humanité
comme si une leçon de résilience que
vous nous donnez là sont des principes
de gardien allemand peut être des
principes de résilience mais je crois
surtout c'est aussi ouvrir une fenêtre
sur des choses à explorer une curiosité
à avoir envie de mettre ses talents au
service de quelque chose qui nous
dépasse
c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup de problèmes
et dangereux à résoudre sur terre
aujourd'hui mais je crois en particulier
pour la jeune génération qu'on doit
garder ses fenêtres ouvertes sur ce
qu'on ignore encore et comme je le dis
souvent et bien parfois l'imprévu ça
peut être un inespéré te dirai merci
beaucoup continuer continuer à
travailler continuer à nous faire rêver
et et continuer aussi à parler à toute
la nouvelle génération vous en parlait
il ya un instant elle a effectivement un
certain nombre de difficultés que nous
ne connaissions pas à notre époque
merci cette émission est terminée on la
retrouve à l'antenne on la retrouve
en rediffusion 1 bien sûr on la retrouve
sur les réseaux sociaux on la retrouve
également replay sur le site internet
rt france.et v merci beaucoup
à très bientôt
[Musique]